madame monsieur chère amie génovéfains
le président de la république a annoncé
cette semaine des mesures visant au
déconfinement progressif de la france
ainsi durant les semaines à venir
plusieurs paliers vont êtres vont nous
permettre d'endiguer la propagation du
virus de lakovic 19 dans ce moment il
est important que nous soyons
extrêmement respectueux des gestes
barrières des protocoles sanitaires
c'est le seul moyen que nous réussirons
ensemble a véritablement éviter la
propagation nouvelles du virus la crise
sanitaire
elles nous obligent au quotidien à nous
réinventer à changer nos modes de vie
nos modes de communication également
et alors que les restrictions sanitaires
nous empêche d'être à vos côtés
physiquement au cours de nos
manifestations dans vos quartiers dans
vos rues il nous faudra dans les
semaines à venir utiliser les nouveaux
moyens de communication numérique de
façon à imaginer nouvelle communication
entre nous au travers de ce type de
vidéos pour vous présenter
pourquoi pas des grands projets qui
concernent la ville et son avenir mais
également au travers de des changes plus
directes entre nous et je pense
notamment à la mise en place prochaine
de facebook live elle doit aussi nous
permettre d'avoir des discussions
comme nous pouvons la voir dans le cadre
de nos permanences et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai souhaité que nous
puissions très rapidement mettre en
place ces permanences visiocom nous en
avions pris l'engagement et au regard de
la situation sanitaire pouvoir les
mettre en place
je le disais il ya quelques instants ces
vidéos elles doivent nous permettre
aussi de revenir sur l'actualité qui
concerne la ville et comment aujourd'hui
ne pas évoquer le conseil municipal ce
conseil municipal a permis d'adopter le
rapport d'orientation budgétaire le robe
comme on l'appelle alors derrière ce nom
barbare c'est simplement la fixation des
grands objectifs et des grandes actions
et des grands projets qui seront
contenues dans le prochain budget le
budget pour l'année
1021 alors ce rapport d'orientation
budgétaire il fixe notre ambition
environnementale en permettant le
déploiement dès l'année prochaine de la
géothermie il fixe notre ambition
environnementale aussi avec une
attention toute particulière à notre
patrimoine boisé conformément aux
engagements que nous avions pris devant
les génovéfains il nous permet aussi de
réaffirmer avec force la place de
l'éducation la place de des associations
la place du développement culturel
artistique et sportif à l'échelle de
notre ville et pour pouvoir le faire
nous avons mis en place des budgets qui
nous permettent de le faire
ce rapport d'orientation budgétaire il
vient aussi témoigner de la bonne
gestion financière de la collectivité
notamment en rappelant que nous
poursuivons le désendettement de la
ville et à titre d'exemple pour la
simple années 2000 21 c'est 1,8 million
d'euros de moins d'emprunts à l'échelle
de la ville c'est extrêmement important
et pour autant nous poursuivrons la
modernisation de nos équipements je
pense notamment à la rénovation
thermique et à la réhabilitation du
gymnase poulidor par exemple dès l'année
prochaine dès l'été prochain
mais ce budget aussi il nous permet de
dégager des marges de manoeuvre
financière pour pouvoir être aux côtés
de celles et ceux qui peuvent avoir le
besoin de la collectivité dans ce moment
de crise extraordinaire que nous
traversons nous avons ainsi souhaité
augmenter les enveloppes financières en
direction du monde associatif ô combien
important sur la vie et nous avons par
exemple décider de d'aller plus loin
encore sur le déploiement de la plate
forme numérique que nous avons mise en
place il ya quelques jours seulement
ma ville mon shopping et qui chaque
semaine compte de nouveaux commerçants
ces importantes que de pouvoir être aux
côtés de nos commerçants eux qui
souffrent si durement depuis le
printemps dernier
eux qui ont souffert si durement d2
confinement ce rapport d'orientation
budgétaire et ce conseil municipal il
est aussi extrêmement important parce
qu'il nous permet d'imaginer
les contours d'une action sociale d'un
accompagnement aussi aux accidents de la
vie et nous définissons au travers ce
rapport d'orientation budgétaire
une nouvelle façon d'être aux côtés des
génomes fn et des jeunes avaient faim
voilà tout simplement leur situation
personnelle et sociale
le nécessite ce rapport d'orientation
budgétaire il laisse aussi une large
place au déploiement de la
vidéoprotection au déploiement de la
police municipale aux acquisitions aussi
de matériel spécifique pour la propreté
de la ville pour l'entretien de nos
bâtiments publics pour l'entretien de
nos espaces verts et c'est un élément
extrêmement important et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous avons aussi un
attachement tout particulier à notre
ville de sainte geneviève des bois
je vais pas être beaucoup plus l'on
traverse cette première vidéo et je vous
donne rendez vous prochainement travers
de nombreuses vidéos pour présenter les
projets alors soit je voulais
présenterait seul soit avec certains
élus aussi en fonction des secteurs
et puis nous nous retrouverons très
prochainement aussi je le disais tout à
l'heure au travers de facebook live et
de permanence visio en attendant je vous
conseillerais simplement de prendre soin
de vous et également de prendre soin des
autres parce que c'est collectivement
que nous arriverons à sortir de cette
période ô combien difficile que nous
traversons tous ensemble